course in my home borough of the Bronx
Trump Links I Drive past it every day
going between Bronx and going between
the Bronx and queens in fact the
Washington Post reported on the Trump
links Bronx course in an article
entitled taxpayers built this New York
golf course and Trump reaps the rewards
where many that that articles were many
New Yorkers and people in the country
learned that taxpayers spent 127 million
dollars to build Trump links in a quote
generous deal allowing President Trump
to keep almost every dollar that flows
in on a golf course built with public
funds and this doesn't seem to be the
only time the president has benefited at
the expense of the public mr. Cohen I
want to ask you about your assertion
that the president may have improperly
devalued his assets to avoid paying
taxes according to an August 24th to
August 21st 2016 report by the
Washington Post
while the president claimed in financial
disclosure forms that trump National
Golf Club in Jupiter Florida was worth
more than 50 million he had reported
otherwise to local tax authorities that
the course was worth quote no more than
5 million mr. Cohen do you know whether
this specific report is accurate it's
identical to what he did at Remagen
Briarcliff Manor do you know to your
knowledge was the president interested
in reducing his local real estate bills
tax bills yes and how did he do that
what you do is you deflate the value of
the asset and then you put in a request
to the tax department for a deduction
thank you now in October 2018 the New
York Times revealed that